député maire conseillers départementaux
ou régionaux ou encore chefs
d'entreprise ils forment le comité de
soutien de françois fillon
ancien premier ministre et candidat à la
primaire de la droite et du centre qui
sait exactement où en est notre pays
notre pays dans l'europe est notre pays
dans le monde et donc par conséquent il
nous paraît celui qui va pouvoir entamer
des réformes très vite parce que c'est
ce dont le pays a besoin
les réformes c'est pas 4 ans après c'est
pas cinq ans après c'est vraiment dès
que le président est élu
qui plus est maintenant nous sommes dans
un quinquennat quinquennat c'est vite
passé
c'est un homme de conviction et c'est le
seul qui a compris qu'il fallait
annoncer les réformes pendant l'élection
pour être légitime et pouvoir les mener
dans les 100 jours sont jours c'est pas
un vain mot
quand on voit la situation notre pays
aujourd'hui il ya vraiment aller très
vite dans le dernier sondage le maire de
bordeaux alain juppé est en tête avec
41% d'intentions de vote au premier tour
devant nicolas sarkozy françois fillon
est lui crédité de 9% savez les sondages
on est un un an de l'élection
présidentielle
on va pas rappeler ce qui s'est passé
entre jacques chirac et edouard balladur
mais quand on va véritablement parler
des programmes
je pense que les français auront vite
vers leur choix
nous n'avons pu nous n'avons eu la
possibilité d'être dans les 2000 mesures
pour être candidat à la primaire
françois fillon doit rassembler les
signatures de 250 élus de 2500 adhérents
et de 20 parlementaires le 21 avril
françois fillon grande et public 72
soutien de parlementaires